so thanks faon for coming know it's a really busy time in the quarter everyone's busy with the homework project and midterms um yeah today I'm going to tell you something I'm really passionate about is uh the speech breing computer interface uh my research so yeah before that so I'm just s some self introduction so I'm cha um from the uh Stanford mptl lab our lab uh trying to build speech Compu build bre computer interfaces to help people restore communication or like restore
movements um so today I think I'm just going to really tell you guys how cool this bre computer interface is given that we have so many uh recent development in the AI and the Machine learning and I hope you guys will can enjoy this talk um all right so let me first start with the video to give you some motivations that why we want to build a uh green computer interface yeah I think what the story tell is that we saw this teenager Howard who's uh 21 at time of this video was shot and he lost all his dreams because
of a severe stroke that also like made him uh in this kind of a locking state where he can't move and he talk about he used to like going out and play football uh making friends and just let her his emotion out I think all this is lost to him and I think the most important thing is that he couldn't really speak to express himself to let all the emotions out so Howard just is just like one of those individuals who suffer from this kind of neurological disease disorder such as brain stamp stroke or AOS that
can cause like severe speech and motor impairment and even complete loss of speech this individuals I think the life is really challenging for them right just think about it you cannot speak you cannot move like you still have a fully functioned brain but everything is lost all all your dreams could be sh other so I think for people like Howard as you just saw in this video the way they can still like communicate with the outside world with their loved one is through this assistive communication
devices such as the one we just saw in the video which is this kind of lead board that has the letters like organized physically and for people like Howard which may still like have there some residual eye movement they can use their like gaze to tell the his friend that where he's looking at and then his friend can use the Gaze to tell what letter he's trying to say just imagine how slow this process is if you want to just say a sentence it might takes you a few minutes to express like simple
things like how are you like I'm feeling not comfortable today like an alternative here is you can also use like a it tracking device so that people can you know use it tracking to uh type on the computer on on virtual keyboard but by you know just think about it if you have to look at the computer screen all the times all day it's really tiring for for them and also like these people are not like us they probably even if they have still have like a residual eye movement it's very hard for them to move their eyes so it's
very tiring as well um maybe something different here is that maybe it's some of you guys have already seen this recently is uh some videos published by a company called neuralink for example here's one video here let me see if I can play them hopefully I can play them all right so I think here is that this company neur link is uh developing this kind of like a tiny uh implantable device that can be actually placed inside your scale and then rate the brain signals um The Hope here is that because
for people like Hardward their brain is still fully functioning so we can the Hope here is that maybe we can using this kind of like a direct interface with their brain so that they can still use their intact brain to control like a computer or even like a robots to help them to live like a normal life and here is a quote from this um their participants noan and he's pretty excited about being able to uh using this very state of art BCI to be able to connect with their families and then being able to support himself I think
this kind of like PCI what I trying to say here that for people like Hardward are like a lot of people who has lost their uh control of their body and language I think BCI can bring hope to them so that's what I'm going to motivate here today is that we're trying to use BCI to really help these people but I think before going into the details about how this is how this works I just want to First go through a brief history of brain computer interface just to help you guys understand how this
thing works like why we can put such tiny devices into the brain and then suddenly can interpret what the brain is doing like there's a lot of interesting stories here so let me start with a brief history of PCI so first uh back to the 19th century here a British scientist called Richard Kon uh started to do some experiments on animals and one of the things he found is that uh you can actually measure the brain activity like measure electricity is from the brain uh moreover if you ask the animal not ask
but like let animals do do some task say moving their heads then you can see that they're like the electricity changes somehow so I think this is the very first early experiments that that scientists do to show that okay actually you can decode some signals from the brain but we still don't know how exactly what those exact like exactly what those electric signals means here so fast forward um to 1924 a German scientist called hansburg invent this device called the yeah I always forgot how to read that word but
anyway so it's show for EEG so it's basically this kind of like on the right you can see that's kind of like this uh electrod that you can play place on the outside of your basically on your scale and then measure this kind of like a wave like um signals so what the scientist hburg find is that uh first first so first he's the first scientist to find that you you can actually measure this kind of like wave like like like signals uh from like just this kind of like a electrod place on
the head and then he found that this kind of signals has very different uh safe frequency depending on how the user how the patient is uh the fun like the state of patient is for example if the patient is in this kind of very calm state that then it will have generate this kind of slow alha wave around like 10 to maybe 20 HZ I don't I forgot the exact range but if the patient is open their eyes and then doing some like a cognitive in tax then you'll see really sharp beta waves so he's the first
scientist to discover that you can actually know the using this kind of like electrodes to measure the brain the electricity electric signal of the brain and also there's a funny story here is that the hburg used to be a used to be a soldier and then one day he was training on the horse and then he fell from the horse and I suffered from a concussion he also has like a twin sister not a twin but he has a he has yes he has a twin sister and then the story is that at the same day her sister felt like
there's a weird something weird and then he just starting to worry about worry about his brother so her sister his sister sent a a telegraph to his his father and telling his brother that is his brother okay so this really intrig hansberger that you know maybe there's something called a telepathy that can connect to uh to people through this kind of like I know whatever this spring wave so that's his motivation to start to study uh Psychology and Neuroscience and invent this EG which we are still
using today to diagn like things like a epilepsy okay um and then people starting to using the this kind of eug devices to perform like to use it to maybe since we can can somehow detect this kind of wave like things from the brain and then we can also control the like the frequency of the wave so someone started like a musician here starting to use this EG devices to um perform music right anyway so I guess you guys already got the idea that someone is controlling like doing trying to perform some music with his
Brin wave I think this is a really cool experiment it's done in I think in the 1950s and you can already see that people starting to um get the idea that you can actually uh bypass like the your body you can actually use your brain directly connect your brain to some like external device and controlling that device so I think the idea here that what if we can also leverage the same idea but to help people with like Hardward you know you can help them to maybe control robotic arm but like the
the problem with this kind of like a EG or external measuring device is that the signal you get is very weak just imagine that uh your brain is generating you know probably know that like the brain has a lot of neurons right the neurons actually generating a lot of like signals and if you just put some electrodes on your on the scalp on the scalp and then what you are actually measuring is like the average neuron firings of like maybe millions of neurons which is if you think about like analogy is that um if you are trying to
see hear what people are saying in the room next to us but we can only trying to figure out like they what they saying in this room what we are hearing is kind of the mumbling of a lot of things we can probably just tell maybe they are in this kind of like a happy mood or maybe they have reached a conclusion but not exactly what they are trying to say so the limitation here is that this kind of EG device can only give us very uh low Precision or like low resolution signal we want to get barer signal so how I
think the answer is trying to go inside the brain and then putting this kind of electrodes next to a neuron and then trying to directly measure the neuro activities of this neurons um and for the purpose of this talk we're mostly going to focus on uh the neurons in this region of the brain called motor cortex so this brain as some of of you may already know that brain has different regions that's doing different tasks so in the center of the brain it's called motor cortex it's basically controlling all your muscle
muscles or or your body muscles so the Hope here that if we can understand the neuron the coding of like the information of neuron that's encoded here then perhaps we can decode this information and use this information to help people like H to to be able to control a external arm or being able to uh speak again um so here's a some very basic neuroscience uh so we know that there's a this kind of cell called neurons right so this is each one of this thing is called neuron and this is the body of neuron called
soma and then this is the axon so this is another neuron so neuron connects through this uh tiny thing called synapse so if neuron has want to transfer some information to another neuron just like in artificial neuron Network you have some uh neurons and then you want to send information to the uh next layer you can basically this neuron will generate some action potential which is just some like a electricity here to signal that another neuron that there is some information there so if you put a a chiny electrod
say on the uh Exon of this neuron here and measure the uh membrane potential which you will get is something like this so you'll have like on the x axxis is the time and on the y- axis is the measure the uh uh electric potential and then you will see this come like a very uh sharp spikes spikes and then if you zoom into this spikes you will see this kind of like a typical firing signature of the neuron which is like the electric like if the voltage suddenly goes up and then goes down so basically what you can measure at the
neuron is that it's kind of very sharp spikes that's what you will get by putting electrodes next to neuron Okay so how do we figure out what like what kind of information is encoded in this uh what call a a spike train um we can perform some Behavior tasks here so for example here uh suppose that we still lessen into a single neuron and this neuron is let's say we're using a monkey for this experiment right so we are instructing training a monkey to do two things uh one thing is basically we're trying to
instruct the monkey to move his uh hands either to the left or to the right and then we measure the firing of the spikes of that single neuron and then see trying to get what kind of information is encoded by that neuron so what you see here is that each row here is basically a spike train of that neuron as you just saw here each vertical line is just a spike of the neuron uh each row is a trial a trial means that the the mon he is try uh just trying to move his hand in like One Direction um then the vertical if you see here
that because like you can see here that the neuron seems to far slightly different across trials so I think that's one like fundamental properties of a neuron is that it's very noisy it's not like in artificial neuron network if you put something you always get something out whereas in a real neuron Network in a neural real neural uh things are really noisy so sometimes they fire a little bit faster but sometimes they fire a little bit slower under the same experimental conditions and so
here what we are trying to measure is that if what kind of information is this neuron encoding when the monkey has mov his uh limb to the left or Lim to the right and then one we can also uh split the this information encoding into two phases one is a preparation and the other is the execution so for preparation for execution execution means that the monkey is actually moving his his his uh his arms where where is the prep preparation means that the monkey is preparing to move but he's holding his
arm fixed so he will actually move his arm at this uh right this go time here so what you can see here that it seems like this neuron um likes to firing a lot during the execution when the monkey's hand is moving to the right and it also fires a little bit more when the monkey is preparing to move to the left so this means that maybe the neuron is encoding some movement Direction here uh so basically if you can repeat this experiments for many different neurons and then for a lot of different
directions and eventually what scientists find is that the neurons like if you fit like say for a single neuron if you fit the the firing rates of that neuron basically how many spikes it's generating every seconds to different uh movement directions you can fit this kind of like a coign tuning curve to it so what this tuning curve means that on the Y AIS is the firing rate and then on the horizontal axis is the movement Direction so this neuron prefers to like firing the most when the movement is say
180 degrees to some reference and then the fireing gradually goes down um so that's like one the first thing scientists find like how the like single neuron encoding like movement information and then if you measure multiple neurons like you will find that each neuron could incode very different informations for example this green neuron here it's tuning curve is slightly shifted to the right and then the magnitude is shifted down so it's preferred direction is around maybe 250 now with two neurons you can
actually decode out more actually decode out what the the intended movement direction is right so for example with a single neuron like suppose right now I measure the firing rate is around like 30 uh spikes per second then there could be two movement Direction with 120 and then 240 however with uh second neurons here you can see that we can basically eliminate the like suppose we measure the second neuron is around five five spikes per second then we can exactly pinpoint that it's the actually the
movement direction is 120 instead of the uh the other one right uh however we know that uh neurons has uh some noises so we actually cannot really exactly tell uh the movement Direction by using two neurons here so for example in the third part here right due to the why the actual like suppose the ground Cho like the the actual fire rate is those gray lines but um due to the noise the firing rate is slightly shift to those Dash lines and you can see that originally if we can decode the movement direction is 120 but in this
case the possibility become that there's four possibilities we cannot exactly we cannot uniquely Define um however you can see that maybe it's still more likely that the the the direction that monkey tries to move is like around 120 rather than the one two Lage is like around 50 and then the other one is more like greater than 240 right so how do we deal with this kind of like a noise in neuron like how can we still uniqu more accurate like how can we still accurately decide decoding this um intended movements from this
kind of like a multiple uh neuron recordings uh I think we can basically use machine learning here right so we can treat this as a kind of like a classification problem so here we are plotting each dot here is basically a firing combination of two neurons and the color here basically represents the the intended move movement Direction and then if you like somehow train a machine learning classifier here then you can basically see we can draw some like decision boundaries where say on the right side
where those uh if like on new measurement that we get that the firing rate somehow Drops Fall onto this here then we probably know that it's going to be the monkey is trying to move to the left direction right uh so okay so I guess here like we know that okay we can do this kind of single neural measurement we can measure firing rates of multiple neurons and then by training a machine learning model we can use this U machine learning models with the neuro data to infer like the what's the likely movement
directions so this is how we are going to build up to uh actually build a uh brain computer interface questions yeah this for all these data you mentioned like neuron one as a very like specific number where how do you pinpoint which neuron can start measuring yeah so here neural one is basically like we are taking so we here make assumption that each tiny electrode here you see is measuring like exactly one neurons and then that electrode will be fixed always be fixed always measuring the fire of that
neurons yeah but in the real case it's not it's not always the case because like you think about it the bra brain is this kind of like a soft structure so if you put electrodes there could move a little bit and measure different neurons so that's one of the challenging problems of uh BC okay is that how you can deal with this kind of neural change recording change yeah all right let's go back to here so now we can basically know that we can put some electrod into the brain into a
motor cortex measure some signals and then we know how the neuron in encodes those signals and then we can also build a machine learning decoder to decode those signals right so can basically have some like methods to be able to build a brain computer interface so that we can interpret what the like a still functioning fully functioning brain trying to do um one more thing is that so how we can record this uh signals so yeah this is a very complicated figure but don't worry about all the details what I'm trying to show
here that basically there's a lot of different technologies that you can use to uh record brain signals but when you think about this technology you can think about it as in this kind of two-dimensional two-dimensional way so on the y axis is the think about as a spatial resolution so the higher so the higher up up you go on the y- axis that means that you can basically measure you you can basically measure like very um the like basically shows like what's the the region like what's the size of
the region of the brain that you can measure so if you go really high up there that means that you can only measure say uh a very large like like the average activ average brain activities of a very large very large Brain area whereas if you go down the Y AIS that means that you can actually measure two very fine green skilles like such as a single neurons whereas the Y the the horizontal access here means like the the temporal resolution that means that for Technologies such as this kind of like a
single neuron recordings you can basically measure like exactly at each time point for example like one milliseconds what's the like electric potential is for that single neuron whereas for technology Recording Technology such as Mi which basically measures like the blood flow in a small brain region it can only measure on average like around like like say 0 five seconds or 1 seconds what's the blood flow changes in that small brain area so that's really like average of a lot of information because we know that the
neuron fire is like this really like fast speed right the firing the electric potential change of neuron is usually around order of one milliseconds right if you can only measure things around like say one second you are basically like averaging smoothing out a lot of informations so ideally we want to have something both have like a high uh spatial resolution and also uh temporal R resolution here um so what we will use in most of this uh right now in a lot of like a clinical trial in our lab is this kind
of like a multi electrod array so each each electrod here is like a tiny needle that can measure maybe a signal of a few neurons and then you put this needles into a small tiny like a square on the size of like a fingernail and then you can measure maybe on order of hundreds of neurons all right so now we can have this uh devices to measure neurons let's go into a more like a uh examples of how we do this here so here's a let's take a example for example here so suppose someone has have a like
say SP spinal cord injury and then lost the connection to his body so his mind is still fully functioning so the question here is that whether we can still what kind of information we can still decode from his motor cortex such that we can decode those informations and then use those informations to either control his arm or like his own arm or like artificial [Music] arm right what we going to do is uh trying to put this kind of tiny electrodes micro electrode arrays into his motor cortex really penetrating into his like
the surface of his motor cortex and each electrod here as you see here is this kind of tiny needle and those uh gr triangle is the size of a neuron so each electrod maybe is measuring the firing potential of multiple like local field potential of multiple neurons around it then we can pass all this information in real time to a computer through this kind of a wire right now and then this what we get on the computer here is that for example here each block is basically the measurement of that one
electrodes and if we do some like Behavior experiments as we just show now we can probably figure out the tuning curve for each electrod for example this one is probably it's preferred direction is to the left right so we can repeat experiments Behavior experiments for other for other channels here and probably train a ml decoder to figure out what this channel each channel is encoding the preferred direction for each channel so once we have the decoder trained and then at test time we can basically ask
our participants who has the thing implant his brain to trying to imagine to move his hand to some directions and then the decoder we're trying to figure out the direction he's trying to move right so that's the basic idea here um let me go to a demo here so this is one of the research coming out of our lab in 2017 so here you see a participant is typing on virtual keyboard with uh with her mind right and then on the bottom shows the typing speed measured as the uh correct characters per minute so it picks around
40 and then on average maybe it's around like 20 I think this is really amazing like think about like four people like Hardward who used to have to um using this kind of ladder board to communicate now with this bring computer interface he can fully uh communicate by himself through a like say a computer so that's a huge improvement over that the board yeah does person open the ey or close the uh he still opens his eyes I mean she's still opens her eyes so is there anything with eye tracking not for
this experiment so even even she closed the eye still work right yeah it will still work but like she won't have the visual feedback you know she won't know where she's typing how about like if she came up with a in a character in in the mind e or R without looking at the keyboard uh okay um that's something I'm going to show next so yeah how do you know whether it's the person who mped or whether it's the machine that's not capturing the correct character like I'm confused by what do
you mean by correct okay oh oh here so yeah that that's good question so let me clarify here I think the task here is uh maybe it's not readable but I think the task here is basically she is copying a sentence so there we know the ground tro then we can measure like the error rate and yeah ask how do you the clicking motion or the like selection motion is is that easy to distinguish or is there a certain way of knowing that the user is pressing down or does she visualize like like a mouse or actually it that's
really good question so as I just mentioned right so we can decode movements and we can also decode like say different gestures say like like say you can use this kind of gestures or like move his uh her elbows so you can just imagine different uh modor movements and then we can basically match decode those modern movements and map that to say a click signal or different signals so was it if the person look at the keyboard and then remember the keyboard in the in her and then she close the eye and it does still
work um I think that's really even like it's that's even hard for me to do right I can't like can you like remember the keyboard and then just control like say Mouse and I use keyboard every day so I definitely remember the word Vis in my mind and I just close my eye but this is like a virtual keyboard so it's not like a physical keyboard we can use your muscle memories yeah so yeah so maybe one thing I have to clarify here that the mental image for her is to say controlling like
a uh like what's the word I mean just just like controlling a like a mouse right so she's not actually doing the touch typing but she is actually moving like say a mouse let's move on all right so this is basically just a showcase that U building up on all the knowledge we have uh learn about the brain so we can basically decode uh some attempted movements from people like uh like uh this I forgot her name but like I think it's T6 that code name T6 that we can really help this kind of people to uh uh
regain communication through this kind of PCI and I think as I mentioned earlier you can also use BCI to control robotics arms so for example in this case this is the participants in uh I think ctech oops he's uh using his mind to control this robotic s which grabs him a [Applause] drink all right hey you finish that thing off that's good and that's there you go all right so and also you can do things like a restore working abilities um I think that's someone just mentioned right now just now is that
maybe uh there's like we can try trying to restore different modalities of communication for example just now we're just using the movements and then using by restoring movements we can control computer but like how about we directly restore the abilities to do handwriting right because handwriting is very um natural ways to uh communicate so uh Frank Frank wet uh research scientist from our lab in 2021 published a paper to show that you can actually do this kind of uh handwriting BCI and he showed
that it's actually really really fast compared to the previous one okay so now we have seen that there's a different ways to restore communication um here's just like a t a measurement of different uh ways of communicating right you can see on the very left is the uh say Sip and puff interface it's very slow basically that means that's for someone who can not really move but can still do uh some like a breathing they can do the kind like a sip and a path to say yes and no to communicate that's
really slow maybe around five words per minute per minute for a normal person I'm really surprised that on average a normal person can write maybe like 13 or 14 words per minute that's really slow but maybe that's just the average speed and on the very far right side is the natural communication which can reach up to 150 and 60 words per minute for minute just put everything into context here so the 2D cursor I just show you guys right now it can do eight minutes for work per per minute eight words per
minute and the handwriting can do around 18 words per minute so compared to the say uh Le board or like uh this kind of ey tracking we are doing like we are really uh make a lot of like advancement here but still it's far way far from like the natural conversation speed so the next question basically is okay how can we get there can we actually restore natural uh can we actually restore speech with a Brin computer interface um um to get there I think there's a huge barrier here first is that um the
language processing in the brain is a really complicated process so for example here is sh all the braing areas that's involved in the language and we still don't know exactly how this happens but this is just the our best guess at the how language is uh processed in the brain on the very right you see that uh there's a lot of brain regions that's involved with uh knowledge and reasoning in the center is uh maybe area that's involved with semantics and uh syntax and on the very
left is about the perception of speech and then the production of uh Speech language is really complex so um maybe the Hope here that we can start with Mod cortex which modor planning of language because things I've just shown you guys that we already know how the model cortex can incode movements right and we can also know that in order to produce language we need to speak and then maybe we can put some electrodes into this part of the modal cortex that actually controls our oral facial muscles and
then trying to decode some information there then see if we can actually restore speech um to actually being able to restore speech is uh I think it's more complicated compared to the restoring movements so what I'm trying to say here is that this the production of speech is really a a lot of a complicated movements and it's really rapid it's just more than just moving your hands to like a certain directions so restoring speech is much harder than just the coding out the those U uh like um movements of each
articulators so in instead of uh trying to decode the movements of each articulators because it's very hard right so also like for people who has uh like hard or people like uh has lost speech it's basically it's very hard to actually measure their uh Speech Artic movements um instead maybe we can try to decode out this kind of like a discrete fums instead of like this kind of continuous speech article Ms because we know that all the languages has this can be decomposed into this kind of basic
fonetic units for example for English we know that there's different vows and different consonants uh they are correlated with how you place your towns in your mouth and how you place your different speech articulators so here we're trying to instead of decoding the actual articul movements we are trying to decode this kind of like discrete phic tokens um and then there's a previous uh work work showing that if you put some electos on the modor cortex and then you can actually tell the differences by
measuring the tell the differences of different fums by measuring the electric activities in the motor cortex so there's a hope of uh being able to restore speech from by just putting elal in the model cortex here and inde so in 2021 uh researchers from UCSF actually demonstrated that's actually feasible to build this kind of like small vocabulary speech PCI with this EOG Recording Technology the difference between EOG and then the micro electral array I just show you guys is that uh whereas the
micro electral arrays actually penetrates into the cortex but the Eco stays on cortex so it doesn't actually record single neuron firing still record some uh average neuro activities over a small region so compared to micro electrod race they will have a slightly lower resolution so that's why their prototype is uh around this kind of like a small vocabulary BC which can only decode 50 words at around maybe 75% accuracy but this is still very exciting work that showcase that you can actually
achieve maybe achieve uh this kind of like a speech decoding using uh uh by putting some en actuals into M cortex all right so I'll just right now go into the research that's done in our lab which is to build a high performance speech neuroth neuro prothesis so in 2022 so we recruited a uh participant code named T12 who has uh AOS so T12 um she used to be a very active person she likes to write horse likes to jog but uh because of AOS a couple years ago she basically uh couldn't do all those
things that she used to enjoy and unlike most Asos uh patients her symptom starts with the artifcial movements first so she still can move her hands a little bit but she cannot really uh speak intelligibly uh so we decided to put four uh micro electrod arrays into her brain two arrays into her modor cortex and then two array into the part of the Brokers area which is supposed to involve with uh uh language planning so the Hope here is that we want to PO decode the the execution of uh of speech the production of speech which is is you
can how you control your your like uh Speech arcs and also maybe decode some like high level uh planning about the speech so that's why want to put arrays into two different brain regions here um so the first thing we do after we put arrays in her brain is that we did some like a Behavior test to see what kind of information we can decode from those arrays so here's a very uh here's a result the first result we got is that we're are trying to classify different uh task here the first plot is that we're trying to using
this four arrays to classify the auto facial movements um so this dash line is the the cue that she's actually executing those artificial movements and then before this dash line she is trying to prefer to do those artificial movements so you can see that this two uh right line here show that you can classify you can classify You can predict those movements much better above chance using this two arrays in the M cortex whereas this two are really in the broadcast area you can basically you can't really predict too much above
chance especially during the execution of those more movements and for single forums which we instruct our participants to speak uh single English fums you can also uh predict those things much higher about like much higher above chance using these two arrays from the model cortex and also for the words for single words right so what this results tell us is that for those two arrays we have put into t12's mind these two arrays in the motor CeX contains a lot of informations about the the fumes being articulated and also the
the words being articulated but those two AR in the broadcast area which is supposed to uh help us to figure out the planning of the speech production doesn't contain too much information so that's really intriguing to us and we're still trying to figure out why why that's true so for the rest of the uh this talk here we mostly using only this two arrays in the motor cortex here so now we know that there's a fanatic informations being encoded in the those two arrays what we're going to
do next is actually trying to build a real time spring to text BCI here so what we're going to do is uh let me just show you a video demo first to you know get a sense of what the the PC trying to build so here this is our participants so she's connect to uh our decoding machines through this cable here which transmits her neuros signals in real time to decoding machine and then on this screen you can see that there's a sentence here that's we instructed her to copy to basically to
read that out and then this once this uh R square turn scen she will try to speak and then what you will see below here is what the machine is [Music] decoded I don't want to call for a babysitter that would be good [Music] I did well in school I don't see much pollution turning on all right so that's the almost perfect decoding results from her and you can tell from the video that although she can vocalize but it's not really intelligible because of her limited um artificial muscle movements
but we can still decode out from her brain signal that what she is trying to say and this video is uh so the task I just show is she's trying to copy a sentence but this is trying to answer a question here I have a very good friend and sister and we also try to different modalities which is uh because when she tries to uh attempting to articulate it's very actually very tiring for her to actually uh to articulate those sounds so what we try here is that only instructed her to move her mouse or move her articulators but
not move but not vocalized so what we call this a silent speech and we can still decode pretty well using this kind of like a silent speech [Music] modality I do not have much to compare it [Music] to I as much as I would like to either all right okay okay so let's just move on more technical details about how we uh build this uh Speech V here so um as I just mentioned right so the first thing we need to do is to try to build a decoder and before building that decoder we need to do some data collection so here is
our research scientist Frank sitting next to T12 and asking her to read that sentence on the screen and then we'll record the new activities of her seeing that sentence so we'll have this kind of a paired data collected paired data where the input is the new activity and the output is the targeted sentence we want to decode so we basically have to basically go to um where T12 Liv and then we'll do some data collection session there uh and then testing the decoder the way we collect data is that
uh because um we only have very limited time and we cannot ask T12 to to to speak a lot of sentences so we'll divide the our data collection into this kind of a block structure where we can start instructed her to speak 40 sentences every block and then she take a break and then we collect another block so the data collection will last about 100 minutes for every research session and then we Crea train a decoder maybe that takes like uh 10 to 20 minutes it's really quick after training a decoder
we'll start actually evaluating the performance of decoder by asking our participants to speak some new sentences and then see how well we can decode on those new set of sentences so in total we did the experiments sessions over maybe three months of time and then we collect about like 10,000 sentences from this T like a switchboard uh tele telephone conversation Corpus which really want to emphasize that we want to decode this kind of conversational English um once we have the data then we
can try to see how we can design a decoder that can best solve this task so let's first Define the problem here so we have some neuro features inputs right so let's say we have some neuro features which is a Time series you can think about as a maybe similar to audio that uh at each time point we'll get some feature vectors um the output of this decoder is a set of words right so we know that she's trying to speak some sentence so we are trying to decode the words from this input neur features
here um as I say as I mentioned earlier so instead of like directly decoding words from the input sentences maybe we want to have this inter media Target of a PHS to decode the reason is that first we know that um there's only 40 PHS in English so that's much small set compared to the number of words so if you want to train decoder I can actually decode words then you will have you need to have much more data to cover all the possible words whereas for PHS you probably need way less data to cover all
the 40 fums here so we inide of decoding directly decoding the words we decided to decode a inter media representation of PHS from the neuro input features okay so basically there's a two decoders we want to design one is the first is a neural to volume decoder and the second is volum to word decoder so that's the two decoders that will have to design this task let's focus on the ne tonium decoder first so basically that's I think at this point of uh class we probably know that we can treat this problem as a
sequence to sequence problem right so the input is some feature sequence output is a token sequence um and for sequence two sequence problem we can probably know that we can use some like encoder and decoder models to to solve this problem right however for encod decod model it's actually more powerful than we actually need because um encod decod model allows this kind of arbitary alignments between inputs and outputs that's really helpful for tasks such as the machine trans ation whereas you know some languages
has like different word orders than other Lang than other languages but here we know that the the alignment is actually is kind of like a more monotonic compared to the like say machine translation where the alignment is arbitrary but monotonic I means that you know that the probably like that the say for example the first two neuro FES probably like corresponds to the first fores in out sentence rather than the last volume in the output sentence right so this is kind of a monotonic alignment um so to solve this problems
of monotonic alignments um we can actually borrow idea that people have de developed for machine learning tasks such as handwriting recognition and speech recognition where the task is also trying to decode a say a ladder sequence or like fum sequence also ladder sequences from some like a uh um Say speech Fe Fe features and the techn we going to use is called connection is temporal classification so for people who have taken CS2 24s you probably already know what this means but I'm going to do some little bit
introduction about this thing I guess I don't have too much time but I just quickly go over it here so what um CDC the connection tempis classification do is that giving some input sequence right the goal is that we want to decode some output sequence but we don't know the exact alignment between them and usually the input output has some lens mismatch for example in the case of like say speech recognition um where the input is uh could be have like a lens of like several thousands of uh frames right
where each frame correspond to a very like fine level like find high temporal resolution featur such recorded at like say 20 millisecond whereas the output only has a few tokens so that's like a huge lens mismatch here what we can do is uh we can still using like say a RN Transformer model to predict what the output token is at each time step right and then we somehow have to figure out a way to fill in between like fill in between the output tokens some like spacers so that output token can also have the same length as the
input output sequence can have the same length as the input sequence so what the CDC loss does is introduce this additional blank token as output um with this blank token what you can actually do is U for example here is a a example output of the CTC classifier it's trying to produce this kind of like sequence here right what you can do is first you merge repeated tokens and then you're taking out that blank tokens so what you get is a much shorter sequence that's correspond to Output so what CDC
loss it does is it allows you to to do a sequence to sequence problem that has a different input and output length and also have this kind of monotonic alignment property um let me just skip through this detail here how you can train a CTC loss here uh just uh skip through this thing so now let's suppose that we have this uh CTC loss that can actually train be used train to to to train our model right the next problem is what kind of decoder we want to use for this task what kind of neural network decoders to
use for this task I think at this point of class I think most of you guys are convinced that Transformer is really powerful right there's no no reason for me to say more about it but in this case we don't want to use Transformer the reason is that we don't have large data set as I mentioned previous we only have 10,000 sentences right and also Transformer is really good at dealing with long range dependencies but here um for the speech production the like there's no re really required for long range dependency so
let's just go back to the very simple RN we know that RN works for small data sets and it can it can predict uh it can deal with short range dependency pretty well and another ni thing about RN is that it can it's very efficient to run in real time you can do like put a very complicated R and even run very efficiently on your on your mobile phone um one like one like the most popular uh RN we have learn ISM right use this this kind of like a memory State here's my cursor uh use this memory state to
trying to store some long long-term like long range informations and then use this um different uh input and forget gate input and output gates to control how you can write read and write into that memory state right um but LM is also very complicated there's a variant ofm called Gru Gator recurring unit it's tries like I think the idea here that just trying to combine this memory State and hidden States into just one hidden state by doing that you can also reduce uh some gates so Gru is basically a more
simple version of lstm that's works really well when you have a small small data set so here we use Gru instead of L lstm for our task so now we know that how we can decode PHS and then we have new network models to decode PHS right we know how to train the model so at inference Time by inference time I mean that at testing time you can pass in some new activities into our decoders and then you will decode out some like phum probabilities right so there's a maybe at the first time stamp the highest probability is I
uh the problem here is that how do I figure out the most likely output sequences giving this fun probabilties right so basically the task is to find the most likely output sequences here um I think for this problem I think since we have already did something similar in the assignment three which is that we can use beam search to figure out the most likely sequence here however this one caveat with the beam search when you're applying it to the CTC LW but I'm not going to expand it too much here um yeah so let's just skip
over that now suppose that we can use the beam search to find the most likely fum sequences how do we convert that fume sequences into words right so that's CU like we eventually want to decode uh a sentences but not just like a a sequence of vums so one thing you can modify the beam search is that you can if you have like a English dictionary where you can map each words into its pronunciations then while doing the beam search we can basically see if you de some fum sequences that correspond to words and
can basically replace that fum sequence with that words right um however you can actually do better by using a language model for example here uh that's the the thing that's the the decoding equation what I want to do here is that uh here the x is the input the Y is decoded the word sequences and then because not all word sequences are have the same likelihood right so some word sequences say suppose I decode a sentence say called I can spoke that doesn't that doesn't seem like a
syntactically correct so we can use maybe use the language model to evaluate the probabilities of each decoded hypo this and then using that as some sort of weight on the final um decoding probabilities so we're adding this extra term here called the probabilities of a sentence here that's actually you can just decompose that into um the probability of each token giving its previous tokens and you can basically measure this things using any language models right now another thing we want to add
here is another term is a word insertion bonus so one problem about this language model this probability of sentences that actually longer sentences will have smaller probabilities than shorter senten that's just like the properties of this how you decompose that how you decompose the this probability here so we want to actually to balance the length of the uh decoded sequence here by adding some word insertion bonus so what we eventually trying to optimize is this equation here using um both the probabilities
generated by the RN decoder and then using some sort of language model like weights and then we insertion bonus and also some ways here you can optimize okay just start trying to put everything together so suppose that you have a neuro feature inputs here which is you get this neuro features every 20 milliseconds you pass that through Gru and now you got some phing probabilities right this is all happens in real time so everything has to be happen under like all computation needs to be down within 20 milliseconds you do a really
quick beam search and then you find okay maybe this this pH corresponds to the word I or the word I um and then here we want to use the angram language model instead of like a more powerful Transformer language model the reason is that we want to really do a lot of like evaluation really quickly under 20 milliseconds so if so suppose that you have like say 100 hypothesis right and then you want to all evaluate the possibility of them if you use a Transformer language model such as gpt3 which is really powerful but you cannot
really like do really fast inferences under 20 milliseconds right so whereas the angram language model you can just load everything into memory and all the evaluation is just a memory lookup so it's really quick after that you can get some probabilities out and then you'll just keep say the top K hypothesis for the next uh step next step of a beam search here so that's how we use the angram language model in the real time uh decoding after that we'll use a Transformer language model so
to uh rerank all the hypothesis generated by the engram language model so this actually happens when you actually decoded out the entire sentence say what I can keep the most likely 100 sentences and then I can at this time I can use the Transformer language model which can quickly evaluate the probabilities say only 100 hypothesis under the time of maybe half a second right and then can get a better probability measurement of other the sentences here yeah so putting everything together this is how the entire system works when
I show you the previous video is that is that we can right now using uh this complicated not comp like multi-stage uh machine learning model to accurately decode what the person is trying to see and build this high performance uh neural uh speech Pro NE speech PCI right we almost time here so I just uh skip the evaluation part evaluation is how we measure the performance is basically measur in the world a rate um it also have a all the data open to as a competition so if you guys are trying really want to curious about this thing
you can try to play around with it I think here's uh I think the most exciting thing about doing this research is that actually see how your research can impact people here so this is a quote from our participant T12 and then this is how she reacts when this thing first worked for her it's really exciting that uh she can speak after so many years of uh uh silence okay so in the last five minutes maybe I can just go a little bit into what I think is the future of uh bcis here so I think what I've just shown you
guys is that using BC we can help people to either restore movements or um restore communication um one exciting Direction I think is this kind of multimodal BCI here is a a work published by group at UCS UCSF is that they are trying to decode not only the phes but also uh Speech I mean the actual speech and then also some articul adjures so that you can actually um move 3D avatars here and also as I just mentioned is that the um uh the the the the final goal of this P PCI is you want to actually deploy it
for people to be able to use it every day just as we use our phones right so um so here's a more recent development of speech PCI by our collaborators at UC Davis what they do is they actually p put four arrays into the motor cortex meaning that they can actually have better uh signals than we do so what they I can actually show is that so for here just for reference because I previous I just forgot to mention that the the final performance of our system is that we can get maybe around 25% word arate means that for every 100
W the participant says uh 25 of them maybe is wrong uh so for this latest to work at the USA d they show that you can actually get close to zero word error rate in uh a few sessions by training the system more and more continously so it's actually being very close to being actually a usable system right now and here's a video of their participants using the system to type to to speak it's very accurate she's he's actually using the system to every day right now to uh for communicating with his family and the
full work that really cannot be understated how important that is all right so I think the most exciting Direction I think happen at least like personally I think is happening in our lab is that um we're trying to maybe trying to restore more effortless and natural communication by decoding this kind of inner speech so previously all the speech PC just show you I think the maximum speed we can do is maybe to at 60 to 7 70 words per minute but that's still far slower compared to Natural competition which
happens at 150 words per minute so one of the reason is that for all this participants if we ask them to trying to attempt to speak because they have been lost speak speech so many years it's very hard for them to speak at a normal rate however we know that we know that a lot of people have this kind of inner speech right we're kind of like talking to our s self in our mind I think the research question here is whether we can decode this sort of like inner speech um so that is like some like a
prelim preliminary work from uh one collaborators in our lab show that you can actually do so so for example here she's our the result show that by if you decode attempted speech which is why I just show you that you can do maybe at the for a small set of work you can do say at the 90% accuracy but if you ask the participants to imagining moving her mouth or imagining like a voice in her head you can pretty do pretty well right so it's not as good as um the a template speech but still much better than much
higher than chance so I think this showing that it's possible in the future that we can decode this sort of like a inner speech to fully uh restore like natural communication to people like Hardward and T12 but I think there's a more a controversial issue regarding this kind of inner speech because what if like you can decode something that's your like your private thoughts or private memories that you don't want to express right that's a very difficult question here and also as I just mentioned not everyone
has UN speech and also someone maybe like when you think about it's kind of like speech right speech is just a external One external representation of your internal thoughts it's just like a linear representation that you want to put out through this kind of like a med like medium of speech whereas your in your thoughts could be more complex more multi-dimensional so it's very hard to decide where you want to put arrays and you where you want to decode all those inner but I think that's also very
exciting opportunities to for us to learn more about like the speech processing in the brain um and I just mentioned like if you want to decode this kind of inner speech then you also coming to this uh facing a lot of new ethical questions um that's really I think thought provoking for example like suppose should we allow bcis to decod read in the memories right like what if like we de something you don't want to say right that's how can we deal with that on the other hand like what if we
can actually use this things to help people who has lost their memories due to like a Alzheimer disease right or we can read out some like subconscious fear that can help people to do their psycho therapies are this like how should we decide whether we want to allow this kind of in decoding or not or you know memory decoding or lot or not and also I think a more like deeper question is like what if like one day we could do this kind of like a cognitive enhancement with BCI such as you know what if you can move a robotic arm much
faster than your real arm is that allowed or like can you actually purchase a memory so that you can skip this CS2 24n class um yeah I think that's really a hard question to answer but it's just like to throw this question out so that you know we're not like it's not like only a PCI problem but we're also facing this problem right now right there's a lot of ways you can do enhancement of yourself so I guess what I'm trying to say here is that b will raise a lot of new a lot of new uh ethical questions
so this is I'm taking this quote from uh this textbook here what it's trying to say is that I think this question is um we're not really looking for answer here but I think the point here that maybe we just want to keep this in discussion with Scientists with Engineers with uh with policy makers and just to make sure that everything know well we we can use BCI to help people that's really need them and and also be aware that there could be some a lot of like potential issues here um yeah I think the just to give a
summary here so I think I've I hope I can convince you guys that BCI is a really cool new research directions it's uh at the intersection of uh AI machine learning neuroscience and neuroengineering uh we'll soon have this kind of like systems that can really help people to be able to communicate again and also it's a really cool opportunity days to understand how the brain process the process languages I think I think the most important thing is that we are bringing hope to people
like horard and T12 all right thank you everyone and special thanks to the people in my last